最近ニュースで闇バイトが結構話題になっ
てると思うんですけどご存知ですかあうん
うんあれは校長的にはどういう風にお考え
です
かああれがねリベラルのおかげでああいう
人間ができたい責任感がないやろでも初め
から犯罪だと分かってるじゃないあれ見て
分からんやったらバカだよねだから分かっ
てても責任感がないとまええやということ
になっちまうもう1つは理性が正しいなら
俺やりたいと思ったらそれは理性や金が
入るから罪の意識がないやろあれらだから
どうやったら罪の意識ができるか責任感が
できるかを考えた方がいいんじゃない今
それができないやっぱりねうちにも大勢き
たんや悪いことばっかりするやつねそれが
何も飛行とか不良とかそういう連中じゃ
なしに小学生の小さな女の子がそうないで
そういう悪いことを平気でやるつまり罪の
意識がないこれらを見てるとね共通校が出
てくるん叱られなかったから叱るというの
は大事なことでね罪の意識ができる罪の
意識のないやつは社会に入れんやろだから
社会性ができないんだああいう飛び跳ねと
むちゃくちゃやるようなやつ罪の意識が
ない社会性がないこれは光らなかったから
そうすると光るより褒めろといったやつを
みんなで吊るししまうやないかそいつの
おかげでどれほどの人間が反社会的な人間
になっちまったのかでリベラルがそいつを
助長したやろ明らかに責任とれよそういう
変な人間を作っちまった通要せ人間を作っ
ちまっ
たコメントで結構あったのが本当に今の
教育は悪くなってるのかっていう質問で
犯罪率とかは現象傾向にあるから実は教育
は良くなってるんじゃないのっていう
コメントが結構ありました犯罪率は昔は
犯罪を起こす素質があったじゃない貧乏な
生活がもうどうしても立ち行かないという
から今でもそういうやつが犯罪起こしとる
やろだからそういうやつ社会からミスられ
たようなそれを作ったのはリベラルちゃん
だから犯罪率じゃないんだ犯罪者の具合な
どうやってできたかの問題ね校長は今の方
が教育が悪くなったっていうのは何を根拠
に
あれだけ登校拒否やっこができてて教育を
成功したとはおこがましいであいつらは
どうするんやあいつらを作ったやつはどう
いう責任を取るんや彼らが一生だめやない
か一生ちゃんと暮らせるように教育をする
んやないのか独立してね独立もできん就職
もできん家から出れんこれ教育がよなった
の投稿拒否は昔から増えちゃってるんです
か業師は昔なかったじゃんあれ貧乏で家の
手伝いをさせるだから学校へ行かして
もらえなかったこれが昔の登校拒否よそれ
であれのね農家のイカの時とか田の時子供
の手も欲しいわねで学校へ行くことならん
家の手伝をしろというのがこれが昔の投稿
拒否よそれを見て法律ができたんや義務
教育小学校中学校は親は子供を学校へ行か
せないといけない親の義務なんだ義務教育
の義務というのはそうしないと親が自分の
子供を労働力に使っちまうそういうことな
んやねそういうことはちゃんと育った
やろう立派にね後で独立することもできた
し今のは違うんや甘やかしたから何にも
できんようになっちまったもう1つは得意
をちゃんとやらなかったからどうしたら
徳育がちゃんとできるか知らんやろみんな
知らんのだだから育はできてない全くと
いうことは人間性が高くなってない人間性
が高くないのを弱いと言うんだ弱いから
社会が怖いんじゃん自分が被害者になる
これが登校拒否じゃない学校恐怖症
やろそれから就職したってうちに来てる
中華料理屋の親さんが言っとったで入って
きて1日おりゃえ方や大体来るのも母親が
連れてくる自分の就職やぞ1日おったら1
週間おったら大喜びせないか日本は潰れる
仕事ができんなんでできんのや怖いんや
世の中全部がなんで怖いんや弱いからや
ないかなんで弱いんだ甘やかしたからや
ないか何でも手伝っちまったから強くなり
ゃしないだけどそれをいいというのがリメ
ラルやないかだから幼稚園幼稚園の頃が
大事なのにねあの頃あ甘やか正やろで
なんか起こったら全部幼稚園の先生の責任
よだったら何にも怒らんように動かんよう
にそっとしておくわね幼稚園だってただ
預かっとくだけになっちまう教育なんかし
ない
よリベラルのいかんのは不快感は悪である
そう言っとるやろこれがいかんのやないか
不快感は全に決まっとるやん不快感がない
と行動せんのだから行動しないと人間は
生きていけんのやから動物なやからねだ
からちゃんと行動できるようにしてやる
これが教育やぞそれを行動させまいとする
そいつようわからんとこれは不快感は善で
あると思わんことにはそんなあれができん
やないか不快感が悪く虐待の定義は子供が
不快感を発生させたらそれは虐待なんだと
馬鹿よね敗者は虐待やで予防注射も虐待や
ぞ子供泣いとるやないかそんなそんな簡単
なことが分からんもう不快感を悪だという
ことにあのするもんでそういうことになっ
ちまう不快感は全なんや怪我してみ痛い
やろ不快感やろその不快感が怪我を直すん
だともかく不快感っていうのは行動させる
細胞の行動細胞が行動を起こして元に戻す
だから怪我が治るこういう風なんよねそれ
をあのバカども不快感を悪だなんて言い
出し子供に不快を与えてはいかんもし不快
が発生したら取ってやれということねこれ
ね動物行動学に最初の頃を乗っとるよノン
フラストレーション児童子供に一切の
フラストレーションを与えるなそうすると
素晴らしい子供が出来上がるに違いない
これリベラルやでそうしたらとんでもない
子供が出来上がってこのまま続けとったら
アメリカは滅びるって言い出しねだから
リベラルをやめたんだというこが生まれた
今の日本の子供みたいなんができた口
ばっかりでとんでもなく臆病で権利
ばっかり主張して義務は果たせないそんな
人間ができたら国は滅びるよそうねだけど
今日本そうなっとるやろそいつがね動物
行動学の攻撃に書いてあるからちょっと
読んでみてこらん前の方に書いてある
から校長先生がいつもおっしゃる今の教育
がダメになった証拠として国力が落ちて
るっていうのもよくおっしゃると思うん
ですけどそれについても伺っていいですか
そうはいはい国力が落ちたのは国力その
ものがね人間性の総合なんだ特に男の女を
怒ったってねあ男が国を盛り立てる仕事を
ちゃんとして製品を作り上げるま女がそれ
に参加するのは拒否はせんけどねだけど
ほとんど男がやっとるんだだから男の能力
やなと能力だけじゃいかんのよそれを発揮
する力それの合計これが国力だで今能力が
なくなりましては能力を発揮する能力を
発揮する行動するということやからね不快
感を嫌って不快感を与えようにしたもんで
不快感を発生する能力が低下しとるという
ことは行動しない特に嫌な行動はしないで
国力は当然落ちる昔日本がアメリカにゼロ
にされてそれから世界第2位までなっで
アメリカを追い抜かとしたもんでアメリカ
が慌ててまたバブル崩壊を起こさして日本
を下げたわな自分たちを抜かんように日本
の今の国力がそんな程度になっちゃって
からあれやったのはねえっと財務省かな
どっかの誰かがそいつを受けてバブル崩壊
を起こさしたんだアメリカから金もらって
やったんよねだけど1人がそることが
できる程度の国力やったそれがリベラル
やっただからアメリカが日本をリベラルに
したのは日本のためじゃないんやアメリカ
のためなんよ
ねこれも1個質問であったんですけど校長
先生は戦前の教育が正しかったって
おっしゃるじゃないですか戦後の日本が
経済で1番伸びたと思うんですけどそこが
矛盾してるんじゃないかっていう質問が
結構ありましたそうやねだけど日本の経済
を伸ばしたのは戦前の教育を受けた人ない
戦後の教育を受けたのは我々以下ねだから
戦前の教育を受けた人が頑張ってゼロに
なった日本を盛り返しちまってそれで我々
がそれを引き継いでまたゼロに戻しとる
我々はダメな戦後の教育を受けた人間は
みんな自分は間違ってないと思っとるんや
けど間違っとるんやでもう実績が示しとる
んよねだから何でもこう盛り上げていく時
が難しいのかそれを維持するのが難しいの
か維持する方が難しいんだ盛上げ人と同じ
だけのことはやらんといかんねよまずねだ
けどあれマスコミがあの頃見てみ働きすぎ
はいかんからみんなと組んではいかんお
祭りもいかんお祭り1回なくなったこと
あるわな今また復活したけどねお祭りは
いかんのや団体を組んではいかんのどうし
ていかんの戦争が起こすから競争はいかん
100m競争みんな1位というあの時代ね
あの時代に育った子供が頑張れるわけない
やろ頑張って1位になるのに頑張らんやつ
と頑張ったやつと同じ1位ではみんな
頑張らんようになるわなあらしなってそう
いう教育をしてないだから頑張りがたらん
わな宣伝の教育っていうのは何が良かった
んです
か大和魂よ大和魂が悪いもんだというあれ
はアメリカが言ったんやねまた大和魂で
やられたらもう1回冷めてくるぞという
ことやだからここで潰しておけばもう日本
が復活せようにしておけば心配ないと思っ
てだけどまだ大和魂の残っとる人が
アメリカを追い越すような経済発展をさし
しまってほでアメリカが慌ててあれして
マスコン民に命令してもっとリベラルを
あれしろとなんかほらリベラルが急に
うるさくなったことがあったわねでそれに
いろんなフロイドを使ったりフロイド
なんてもうあんなの間違いだということが
分かったようなものを使って我々のような
とこを攻撃したわねあるいは共産主義者が
アメリカはけしからん日本はロシアにつく
べきだという馬鹿な共産主者どもが一生
懸命国力を弱しようとした今でも言っとん
の知っとる昔日教争社会党やったねで社会
と教育は社会等に任しておこうとそうする
と日本は潰れる潰れる寸前に革命が
起こせるぞっていうんやこれが左翼の言っ
とることやでだから日本を潰すことを前提
としてみんなやっとるんや左翼はねから
そんなとこがアメリカのリベラルと一緒で
いつまでも信頼されるわけないじゃん教育
で親は困っとるやろちゃんとした教育をし
てくれりゃ自分はこんな風自分とこの子供
はこんな風にならんやったところが
5080問題ってのは80歳に親はなっ
ちまったもう稼げないよ子供が50歳に
なってまだ1年前になれん仕事しないで親
の年金で一家全部が暮らしとる親はん
やろ安心して自分が死んだら子供飯の
食い上げ580問題これがものすごい増え
ちまっとんやけどマスコミは報道せんよう
にしとるじゃん自分たちのやったことだし
未だにあの左翼っていうのは革命に憧れ
とるんやバカなことにね日本は革命が
起こらなかったことを誇りにすべきない
外国はヨーロッパでもトップがダメだから
革命が起こるわけやろ中国でも日本は
トップが良かったから革命が大きいんやっ
てそれと日本人独特の和の精神だから和の
精神ってなんか知らんからねワットは
みんな仲良くだぐらいでごまかしちまうん
よえっとね私の言うことは正しいこと
ばっかりだだから今からまだ続くからえー
正しい
人生死ぬ時に満足の行く人生それをり
たけれ
ばチャンネル登録してずっと聞いてくれ